and then I facepalm go right back into a
dumpster that's a true story I was there
I closed the lid but like she was okay
right oh yeah totally
know what we're all uh we're all still
friends so we're gonna go get some fresh
drinks do you guys want anything
yeah I'll take it fresh um yeah me too
thanks old fashioned up sure we'll be
right back
yeah don't go anywhere oh my god this is
going incredibly well things are finally
happening best buds hot girls I still
can't believe you gotta say yeah bro
ever since I got that ride up is one of
the top hundred tastemakers to watch in
2014 my DMS have been just like flooded
with invites that's actually really
impressive what magazine was that again
oh it's like this site that my friend
runs I told him if he didn't put me on
the list I would kill myself number 98
boom we've got a problem
Garrett there are literally no problems
in the world we should get out of hot
tub like right now bro that is a huge
negative water is way too hot I don't
want to say the B word
Gary do not say blame you're actually
boiling you are being dramatic what is
hotter the water or those two smokin hot
babes mind you one of them is Australian
definitely the water bro they told us to
wait here do not blow this for me Quinn
we can't regulate our body temperature
we need to get out no Garris just wait
outside of the hot tub what's the big
deal okay things have been happening
under the surface but between me and
Cindy it's special things queen don't
I've got a boat I got it technically
it's a long softy but uh okay I'm
definitely getting rope no do not leave
me there is nothing creepier than being
a lone dude in a hot tub at a party
Flynn solo before but never this close
to the Sun care just don't say anything
crazy see see right there there that's
exactly what I mean you're the guy in
the tower
talk to me out of pollen too many hot
shot move cuz you know I'm gonna pull
hot shot moves going wait Cindy said
that Jenny said that you reminder of a
young Alec Guinness boom there it is I
said it you're kidding I wasn't gonna
tell you I didn't want to inflate your
ego Sir Alec Guinness circa West circa
Bridge on the River Kwai sir could be on
the RK that's primetime young in prime
time young Guinness I mean it'd be rude
if we left right it would be offensive
okay okay we'll stay in the hot tub for
one more drink
but then
Oh oh no Quinn Quinn Quinn Mike my arm
my arm is numb your hand right let's
keep our heads okay I can't see out of
my left eye
ah no they're right I can't see anything
I'm blind I'm totally blind I'm just I'm
gonna I'm gonna try to float my body
towards the edge of the tub stay calm
you don't need to see to keep backing on
these Quinn
I've lost equilibrium oh there goes me
too
no regrets I'd do it again if I had the
chance all that underwater touching was
worth it
Bernie grazing my knee wait that's that
seat you just touched me it felt amazing
Garrett it was so hot I have so many
regrets we probably shouldn't have told
that story about pushing your sister
into the dumpster going to ground
control
go ahead Quinn I want you to know
something what is it quick I made the
whole thing up about about Cindy Styne
you look like a young Guinness she said
you look like Jar Jar Binks Oh Cindy
Cindy you're back yes I knew it I knew
we had a connection we lost your
equilibrium if you could just grab my
arm and pull me
wait is that butter Oh Cindy you are bad
I love it oh no Quinn and you're both
wearing those super sexy little bits
with uh with the little lobster so oh my
god you're gonna murder us usually when
I stop screaming Cindy
you